le Festival de Cannes c'est aussi
l'occasion pour certains réalisateurs de
montrer leur tout premier film cette
année Marie-Ange Casalta est venue
présenter son premier court-métrage ça
s'appelle The Last diner un film avec
notamment François-Xavier de maison
c'est l'histoire de quatre potes 4 amis
qui quittent New York Manhattan pour
passer un petit week-end à la campagne
dans une zone où il y a pas de réseau
ils sont vraiment isolés du monde et
durant une partie de Scrabble il faut un
pari sur l'existence d'un mot ésopia
est-ce que ça existe vraiment et Paris
500 dollars et celui qui est certain que
ça n'existe pas décide de sortir je sais
ce qu'il est du réseau pour chercher sur
google si le mot existe vraiment et là
qu'est-ce qu'il apprend il apprend que
c'est la fin du monde en 20 minutes il
va y avoir une attaque nucléaire sur
toute la côte Est aux États-Unis et
retour dans la maison
est-ce que je leur dis où est-ce que je
veux je leur dis pas voilà j'ai 20
minutes avec mes meilleurs amis est-ce
que je leur dis ça pose une vraie
question existentielle et pour tourner
ce film dont l'action se passe aux
États-Unis dans le Connecticut
Marie-Ange Casalta a trouvé l'endroit
parfait et il se trouve dans les
Yvelines pour tourner ce film on sait
vraiment pris la tête sur le lieu du
décor vraiment on a visité des tonnes de
maison il fallait que ça fasse américain
qu'on y croit vraiment qu'on soit dans
le Connecticut ok il fallait aussi qu'on
ait aucune habitation autour puisqu'ils
sont coupés du monde ils sont au milieu
de nulle part c'était pas facile
honnêtement il fallait pas que ce soit
pas trop loin de Paris parce que j'ai
pas de venait de Londres François-Xavier
tous les comédiens voulaient pas les
faire voyager depuis toute l'équipe donc
on a trouvé cette maison incroyable qui
se trouve à Mareil-Marly qui s'appelle
la canopée c'est en fait c'est une sorte
de gîte où ils font beaucoup de yoga
beaucoup de choses comme ça c'est coupé
du monde c'est dans la forêt c'est un
lieu vraiment magique avec une âme
vraiment et la propriétaire était
formidable et nous a dit ça me fait
tellement plaisir que vous tourniez ce
film ici je veux que ce lieu vive qui
vive plein d'expérience différentes donc
on c'est tous très heureux on a tourné
là sur deux jours au mois de janvier une
grosse partie du film ce tournoi à
l'extérieur se passe à l'extérieur on a
eu extrêmement franchement ce que j'ai
eu le plus froid de toute ma vie on a
tous dit qu'on avait mis une semaine à
ne plus avoir froid après je te jure
c'était tellement vrai oh là là le froid
en pleine forêt au mois de janvier mais
tout le monde a été incroyable on avait
des chaufferettes partout et
c'était l'endroit idéal puisque tu
regardes le film et tu te dis vraiment
les gens ne peuvent pas croire qu'on
n'était pas au fin fond des connectiques
quoi donc l'endroit était parfait
[Musique]
binaire un film de Marie Ange cazalta
que les festivaliers pourront découvrir
cette année à Cannes le 24 mai au Short
Film Corner